c'est un projet de loi qui était très
attendu évidemment on est très loin de
la décentralisation de faire ou de la
décentration raffarin certains textes
qu'on peut qualifier à minima et qui de
ce fait a entraîné naturellement une
déception des grandes associations
d'élus qu'il s'agisse de régions de
france se démerdent français et de nous
mêmes mais en même temps il ya des
choses à comme le disait andré bergeron
il ya du grain à moudre des choses à
prendre
certainement beaucoup de choses à
modifier mais je fais confiance aux au
sénat et à sa commission des lois pour
pour le faire et bien sûr au travail qui
pourrait être fait ensuite à l'assemblée
nationale donc c'est un texte très
technique qui ne met pas fin à une
période qui a été depuis quelques années
très très centralisatrice et qui ne
tient pas compte non plus des réflexions
que nous avions fait en particulier
devant votre commission d' enquête sur
les conséquences de la crise sanitaire
et les modifications qu'on n'eût pu
apporter à notre organisation
salutaire je veux pas rentrer dans le
détail je vais prendre quelques exemples
tirés de ce texte vous souvenez quand on
était ici
g t au t2 la commission des lois de
l'assemblée en commission mixte
paritaire en 2015 avant la discussion de
la loi d'autres nous avions mis un peu
d'espoir dans les conférences
territoriales de l'action publique
lisant ça peut être le lieu où on se
coordonne entre régions départements
grosse pci et
en réalité ça n'a pas fonctionné à part
quelques rares exceptions alors
l'absentéisme il est totale et la
plupart des élus ne viennent plus donc
on pensait c'est à l'article 3 du projet
de loi trouver une une modification des
ct ap est en réalité sur les transferts
de compétences qui peuvent être discutés
on a une situation qui était assez
bloqué qui ne bougent peu par rapport à
la situation actuelle
après il ya la sphère du transfert des
routes donner un exemple a narré par les
a plus beaucoup de routes nationales
appartement comme lemire la
charente-maritime 6000 km de route
départementale 138 km de routes
nationales
on a des délais direction interrégionale
des routes et celle avec dominique
perben à l'origine de leurs créations
mais j'en suis pas plus fier que ça
parce que aujourd'hui leur carte ne
correspond plus à rien et on a des
équipes de l'état qui sont parfois dans
des enclaves départementale pour des
bouts de réseaux routiers nationaux
compte beaucoup de départements ont dit
à l'état on est prêt au transfert des
routes nationales condition bien sûr
qu'on discute des conditions de
transfert du personnel et de l'état du
réseau routier qui nous est enserré là
encore il ya eu très peu de concertation
connaît pas la carte des routes qui
pourrait être transféré le gouvernement
nous dit qu'il a discuté on ne sait pas
mais qui puisque aucun département n'a
discuté avec le avec l'état et
complique aussi les choses en faisant
entrer les régions qui n'en demande or
qui ne demandent rien sur les routes à
part à part mais maintenant c'est réglé
par la création de la collectivité
européenne d'alsace leurs revendications
qui datent de daniel hoeffel de de
pouvoir contrôler la rive gauche du rhin
pour éviter que les camions voulant
échapper à la cave et ma hotte allemagne
viennent sur la route sur l'autoroute
gratuite du côté français donc un
article 7 qui prévoit une
expérimentation de cinq ans lorsque les
régions sont compétentes pour aménager
les routes non c'est pas très bien à
quoi ça ça correspond d'autant plus que
vraiment les routes les les les régions
ne le demande pas autre exemple de
louper dans ce dans ce texte
là la santé je pense que nous avons tous
la même expérience de la crise est en
tout cas la première celle du printemps
de l'an passé pendant laquelle à part
peut-être l' agence régionale de santé
d'ile-de-france où les relations les
élus avec son directeur général aurélien
rousseau on était fluide sur le reste du
territoire ça c'est pas toujours très
bien passé
moi j'ai exemple dans mon département 1
14 morts dans un ehpad en temps présent
département cotutelle je ne suis pas au
courant le maire n'est pas au courant le
préfet n'est pas au courant
naturellement de cabinet d'olivier
ferrand lui même pas au courant tout ça
on apprend par la presse en pleine crise
donc il ya vraiment eu un souci donc
nous nous souhaitions entrer dans les
dents les conseils de surveillance d d d
ars les régions de france et nous les
soutenions souhaite à la limite que le
président de la rs soit le président de
la région
on aurait pu penser à un mode de
désignation des directeurs généraux
ressemblant à celui nos colonel de
pompiers c'est à dire là le cauchois du
préfet en l'occurrence préfet de région
ou une mise de la santé et le président
de la région tout ça et est tombé à
l'eau
et donc on reste une gouvernance très
parisien des ars qu'on reproduit
l'avenue de ségur au niveau local avec
les mêmes blocages que vous connaissez
bon il ya des choses qui vont dans le
bon sens dans menée en moins dans le
domaine de la santé la possibilité aux
collectivités de financer l'ensemble des
établissements publics de santé
le camp nous gérons des centres de santé
dans ce département de saône et loire
qui s'est lancé dans une politique de
recrutement de médecins de mise en place
d'un dispositif très intéressant donc
possibilité de recruter évidemment des
professionnels non laboratoire
vétérinaire c'est vrai qu'on a eu
beaucoup de mal
moi je batailler ferme et coup se
verront elle fut monté jusque opposant
la république pour obtenir pendant la
première période difficultés sanitaires
qu'on puisse qu'il puisse participer aux
tests et ça parce que bon alors
maintenant cessé retenu leurs
compétences ont précisé
en matière d'habitat exclusif et ses
prières des choses positives problème de
la recentralisation du rsa alors
contrairement à ce qu'on pensait pas un
problème droite gauche
il ya des présidents de départements de
gauche farouchement pour 113 élus rsa
type stéphane troussel en seine saint
denis et des présidents socialistes de
départements farouchement conti plus
jean luc chenut dans le département
d'ille et vilaine donc c'est disons
qu'ils sont les départs de la dizaine de
départements partisans leurs centrales
sont durs et ça c'est soit des pauvres
ruraux donc voilà donc type corrèze
creuse soit des grands départements
urbains en difficulté sociale
donc la majorité de l'adf toutes
tendances politiques confondues est
content parce que nous pensons qu'il ya
un lien entre le fait de verser cette
allocation et les politiques d'inclusion
que nous menons sur le terrain et nous
voyons pas d'ailleurs comment l'état qui
n'existent quasiment plus haut niveau
départemental sauf à l'échelle des
régions seraient capables de gérer cette
affaire
ceci étant la loi
le projet doit 4d permet une
expérimentation dans un certain nombre
de départements donc pour votre
information certains départements ont
commencé avant même que vous n'ayez vous
ne soyez saisie en séance de la loi
travailler sur ce texte sur cette
possibilité je leur souhaite bien du
plaisir on avait quasiment réussi avec
manuel valls il ya quelques années à
tomber d'accord sur l'année de référence
évidemment bercy est arrivé est l'année
de référence a changé et donc
l'opération n'était plus viable pour les
départements dont cassel départements
qui ont déjà dit à chacune gouraud qui
souhaitait expérimenter cette
recentralisation ya un dossier qui est
un peu compliqué la clé plus clivants
sur le plan politique sont les le
recours obligatoire au traitement
automatisé d'appui à l'évaluation ça
s'était retirée si vous allez retrouver
dans le projet de loi en france
c'est au départ dans quatre des là c'est
parfois un peu politique au sein de
l'adf nos collègues de gauche sont pas
très pour les autres plus tôt
mais majoritairement les départements
sont favorables à ce dispositif mais
vous le retrouverez dans dans un texte
taquet à venir s'il est inscrit à
l'ordre du jour 2 de la haute assemblée
bon il ya un certain nombre de choses en
matière de rh positive il ya là deux
négative c'est ok je me permets
d'attirer votre attention et seront
terminés là monsieur le président nous
avions demandé à le transfert des
gestionnaires de collèges et lycées
pourquoi c'est pour les régions jeu
collège pour nous parce que ce sont des
hommes et des femmes qui travaillent
avec nos crédits et nos personnels pas
un sou de l'état et tous les personnels
sont de la collectivité dans les
collèges et lycées et on a le plus grand
mal à obtenir des choses de moi jouer
dans mon département je voudrais que
tous les enfants soient initiés au moins
une à deux fois par semaine au bio sur
51 principaux j'en ai 32 grands accepté
mais 19 qui sont habitués à travailler
sodexo qui travailleront jusqu'à leur
retraite avec sodexo qui refuse de se
compliquer la vie en achetant du bio
local ou régional
bon donc nous avons dit au gouvernement
transféré nous ces gens là alors ils
seront toujours sous l'autorité
fonctionnelle du chef d'établissement
mais ça devient des gens qui fuient qui
sont sur notre autorité lui le mit la
rue de grenelle s'est mise en travers
plus qu en travers finalement et un
arbitrage comme toujours en
interministériel un peu un peu
bizarroïdes sur le thème expérimentation
3 2 3 ans moi je permets de suggérer à
la haute assemblée que le sec le premier
ministre ne sera pas contre bien au
contraire de mettre fin à
l'expérimentation de trois ans et qu'on
passe directement au transfert de ses
personnels
je me rappelle les cris d'orfraie des
tos en 2003 quand époque raffarin pour
quand on les a transférés auparavant
leur carrière et est gérée depuis des
ordinateurs rue de grenelle sans qu'ils
connaissent personne maintenant ils sont
dans leur département ils sont dans les
commissions ils voient les gens et leur
carrière sont sont tout à fait
différentes sur le plan de la gestion rh
puis enfin dernier point le président
médecine scolaire médecine scolaire
c'est un scandale national
quand il était au lycée très peu un
gamin là un médecin dans l'iss est dans
chaque lycée
aujourd'hui il ya un médecin pour douze
mille élèves en france je parle pas la
pédo psychiatrique est à l'abandon
donc nous avons proposé de prendre la
médecine scolaire
sachant que ça va nous coûter de
l'argent qui sera recruté mais un manque
de terrains mais qu'on pouvait faire un
grand service de médecine de la petite
enfance à l'adolescence avec la pmi
quelle est notre responsabilité donc
faire un ensemble commun est là ou non
du fait que dans cette période difficile
il faut pas déranger les habitudes du
ministère de la santé oms nous envoyer
paître et je le regrette
voilà donc en conclusion de ce texte
naturellement nous sommes dans des
négociations financières par ailleurs ge
en forme la commission avec l'état parce
que nous avons peur des chiffres du rsa
en 2020 ont peur qu'après la des petits
commerces des restaurants des toutes
petites boîtes en difficulté à l'automne
mais qui sont passés au travers des
différents dispositifs dette de l'état
des collectivités fermé leurs portes
donc on trouve un certain de gens se
retrouvent au chômage plutôt âgés en fin
de carrière donc on les retrouve au rsa
donc nous étions d'ego siècle le
gouvernement une clause de sauvegarde
sur l'airé ça qui nous permettrait s'il
y avait d'un effet de ciseau dans
certains départements de le jeu est bien
dans certains départements de de le
compenser parce que globalement dois
vous dire la vérité je n'ai pas là pour
pleurnicher les dm théo cartonne et
droits de mutation cartonne peut-être un
peu moins dans les ardennes qu'en
charente-maritime ou dans le var mais
pour l'instant l'effet de ciseau ne se
produit pas mais je pense partement de
patrick kanner avec un département comme
le nord où d'autres pas sûr que ça dure
et donc qu'on est en train de discuter
avec matignon et bercy un certain nombre
de clauses mais c'est en dehors bien sûr
de la discussion du projet de loi cadets
donc en conclusion nous nous prenons on
va prononcer la loi ça posera nous il ya
des améliorations
claire est intéressante mais ça reste
très technique parfois même un peu
techno et c'est dommage que
et par une carriole de décentralisation
cas sexe comme il ya eu une période de
fer droit de faire et chirac raffarin je
pense qu'on pouvait aller plus loin et
surtout en tirant plus les leçons de la
crise sanitaire
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
merci mesdames et messieurs merci
monsieur le président alors madame gatel
monsieur arnaud merci beaucoup monsieur
présent monsieur le président merci de
votre intervention donc le sénat par la
bouche de son président a exprimé un
constat qui est à peu près le vôtre
c'est à dire on a un fils ténus on
remercie la ministre de nous le proposer
mais que nous considérons qu'il y a un
certain nombre non agissements juste
pour un objectif qui dépasse la lettre d
qui l'a l'aide du 1e d'efficacité de
l'action publique et nous partageons un
certain nombre de vos constats alors les
articles à caractère social ont été
confiées à la commission des lois sur le
fond mais j'aurais cependant quelques
questions autour du sujet plus générale
des ressources humaines et de
l'adéquation compétence gestion des
ressources
alors peut-être tout d'abord sur les
trois premiers articles ou notamment le
titre de ce projet de loi sur alors 3ds
aux cadets en tout cas il ya un mot
différenciation dans l'article 1 il ya
un copié collé d'un article qui est la
reprise de la constitution donc quelle
est la valeur ajoutée de dire que on
peut faire de la différenciation s'en
aller un peu plus loin et sans définir
donc que pensez-vous de la sécheresse ou
de la pertinence d'une réécriture de
cette nature on a un vrai sujet sur le
pouvoir réglementaire locale nous il
nous semble que dès lors que
des collectivités ont des compétences
compte tenu de la diversité de leurs
besoins et des réponses à mettre en
oeuvre sans doute faut-il permettent
d'exercer des adaptations locales et non
seulement confié au préfet un droit
dérogatoire mais également permettre aux
collectivités d'adapter les choses
deuxième point on a parlé des
décentralisations proposait donc mathieu
darnaud parlera plus particulièrement
des routes moi je voudrais parler d'un
un sujet que je ne comprends pas le
principe étant que quand on doit exercer
des compétences on avoir des ressources
et je ne parle pas des ressources
financières mais des ressources humaines
la loi climat et résilience va faire
obligation aux collectivités notamment
pour reprendre votre exemple
d'introduire puisse l'approvisionnement
en bio ou en circuit court
or ni les départements ni ni les régions
n'ont l'autorité sur les personnels
comme comme des personnels de
restauration comme vous l'évoquez donc
seriez vous d'accord pour que le sénat
ait un peu plus loin vous l'avais dit en
termes de médecine scolaire
ce n'est pas un caprice de dire que les
infirmières scolaires doivent être
attachés aux départements mais
aujourd'hui il ya une indigence de ce
service ce n'est pas la faute de ces
personnes mais elles sont un peu en
électron libre et le département a la
compétence et a surtout beaucoup
d'outils pour mettre en oeuvre au
service des enfants ou des familles en
difficulté et que c'est dans les écoles
qu'on peut repérer qu'on peut repérer
des enfants en difficulté qu'on ne voit
pas dans d'autres milieux donc nous ne
serons assez exigeants là dessus il y à
un sujet sur les m and à nous nous nous
nous avons nous avons une vraie question
là dessus sur
sur les haies mais n'a que pensez vous
de la proposition qui avait été faite
dans les 50 propositions du sénat je
pense que vous vous deviez l'approuver
parce que vous étiez autour de nous si
je puis dire
on a proposé de recentraliser la prise
en charge des mineurs non accompagnés
l'article 39 propose une option
différente et rs la charge aux conseils
départementaux et enfin vous l'avez
évoqué sur les ehpads notamment où il ya
une double tutelle serre si cette
question de compétence partagée entre
l'état et les collectivités les ehpad
une double tutelle les tailles les
départements et je me permet très
souvent dans les auditions que nous
avons de citer l'exemple que vous citez
d'ehpad où il ya eu des clusters ou le
président de département a plutôt été
informé par la presse que par le
directeur de la rs voici mes questions
monsieur le président merci mais un
média tel monsieur d'arnaud et puis
ensuite monsieur k nerfs merci monsieur
la pression parole à monsieur bussereau
le temps nous est en compte et je vais
m'efforcer d'être particulièrement
synthétique
j'avais trois questions à vous à vous
poser la première s'agissant finalement
de ce qui constitue un peu l'écueil de
ce texte
au delà de savoir s'il y a une audace
décentralisatrice ce qui nous semble
manquer cruellement c'est la question
des moyens et l'accompagnement des
transferts de compétences et pour
revenir à un point qui évoquait entre
les lignes françois gatel sur la
question des routes
parce que si les départements sont
sollicités il n'en demeure pas moins et
j'en suis l'exemple représentant le
département de l'ardèche que certaines
certains de nos départements ont des
fortunes diverses et se trouverait selon
moi après que le transfert de la route
était accompagnée de moyens dans des
situations compliquées pour en assurer
le fonctionnement ça c'est le premier
point
j'aurais aimé savoir ce que pense le
président de l'assemblée des
départements de france du fonctionnement
des ct ap
parce que pour nous disons les choses
très clairement et je vais le dire sans
ambages il s'agit en quelque peu d'un
ovni qui fonctionne dans quelques
régions je pense notamment à la région
bretagne mais
toutes les auditions que nous avons
réalisé des bouches tout sur le même
constat c'est à dire que là c'était ap
c'est au mieux une chambre
d'enregistrement
un lieu de palabres ça n'a pas que des
inconvénients mais les attentes et les
espoirs qui avaient été placés dans les
cités ap aujourd'hui sont relativement
déçu et puis dernière question pour nous
elle est importante parce que on
voudrait redonner un petit peu de
souffle à ce texte
on est très attachés ici au sénat au
département on n'a cessé de le dire et
sans revenir sur les équilibres en
matière de compétences existant
aujourd'hui on souhaiterait et cette
période de crise l'a démontré que le
département puisse avoir cette agilité
nécessaires en période de crise quelle
qu'elle soit mais dans le quotidien pour
prendre en compte au delà de la
définition de la différenciation les
besoins spécifiques de certains
territoires je pense notamment à
l'action en vis-à-vis du commerce de
proximité
je pense notamment des questions liées
aux mobilités le fait que le département
et il y à des sujets il ya des
départements je pense notamment au
cantal et d'autres qui ont des besoins
tout à fait singulier et il est parfois
compliqué d'entendre que le département
n'a pas la capacité d'intervenir donc
voilà quelle est la position en
j'imagine plutôt favorable mais pour
nous c'était pour nous c'est important
parce que on sent bien que derrière ce
texte les élus quels que soient les
associations d'élus appelle notre
attention sur ce besoin d'agilité de
réactivité par rapport à la question de
la proximité et aux attentes de nos
concitoyens
merci monsieur arnaud ce canard et merci
monsieur le président merci monsieur
2000 bussereau vous êtes ici au sénat
j'ai envie dire le plus beau cercle des
présidents de conseils généraux disparu
ce que quelques-uns qui se traîne dans
cette haute assemblée
donc nous sommes d'autant plus attentifs
à votre propos et merci d'avoir cité le
nord tout à l'heure le texte et contexte
ce texte est faiblard il est faiblard il
intervient en fin de quinquennat et la
prospérité de ce texte y compris dans
son parcours législatif interroge
notamment à l'assemblée nationale
néanmoins il faut y travailler
nous remercions bien sûr nous rapporteur
sur le sujet vous avez notamment évoqué
quelques sujets très précis et je
voudrais revenir sur l'un qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur et qui est
celui de la santé dans une logique de
blocs de cohérence que je préfère même
cette notion de bloc de cohérence à bloc
de compétences
parce qu'à un moment donné il faudra
bien reconnaître que les partage de
responsabilités ne sont toujours pas
très claire aujourd'hui entre les trois
échelons voir les quatre si on y rajoute
l'intercommunalité dans le bloc de
cohérence santé prévention la médecine
scolaire pour moi fait partie
évidemment dans l'enjeu majeur on doit
permettre au département de gérer un
petit scolaire et du plus jeune âge
jusqu'au lycée toujours dans cette
logique de cohérence
vous avez évoqué président la question
bien sûr des ressources pour assumer un
vrai service et c'est vrai que les
départements ont le savoir-faire ils ont
l expertise au travers de la paix mis au
travers de bien évidemment de la
planification familiale au travers des
bilans quatre ans enfin genre à dire de
la prévention santé pour beaucoup
d'entre eux donc les départements sont
les mieux placés la question des
ressources peut aussi se poser par
d'éventuels transferts vers l'état et
moi j'ai toujours été je crois que
certains dont j'ai entendu ma théorie
sur le sujet je considère que dans cette
notion de bloc de cohérence le blog
sûreté sécurité devrait intégrer les 10
très concrètement et je ne vois pas pour
le département l'intérêt de d'être
gestionnaire de se disent alors que cela
relève de l'autorité hiérarchique du
préfet je sais bien que je me fais pas
que des amis en disant ça je sais quel
est le travail qui a été celui des
départements pour améliorer le
fonctionnement des indices au travers
des cendres le jeu court des matériels
et les pompiers public parfois un peu
compliqué mais les pompiers nous
remercie parce qu'ils n'ont jamais été
aussi bien servis en termes de matériel
de sang de secours qu'il était
précédemment mais néanmoins c'est le
préfet qui reste le patron qu'on le
veuille ou non et donc je voulais savoir
si cette idée de dire mais nous prenons
la médecine scolaire parce que c'est
notre savoir faire
c'est notre compétence mais en échange
nous transférons vers l'état d'autres
services et je pense en particulier aux
services de secours est ce que cela est
une idée iconoclaste je n'en doute pas
un seul instant mais qui moi méritent
une peut-être une interprétation de
votre part en terme de réponse
merci monsieur bussereau président
monsieur le président merci trois
orateurs de leurs questions chères
françoise gatel présidente
je m'interroge un peu sur l'article 1
comme vous j'aimerais bien savoir ce
qu'on a pensé le conseil d'état ne sais
pas
ce qu'en pensera aussi le conseil
constitutionnel c'est vrai qu'il est
coupé de maps qu'on est on peut pas dire
qu'ils en qui déclenche un enthousiasme
pour un premier article d'un texte de
loi qui se veut décentralisateur donc je
partage vos interrogations et peut-être
pourrez-vous obtenir du gouvernement
dans la discussion devant votre
commission ou dans l'hémicycle un
certain nombre de précisions sur cet
article
je partage complètement ce que vous avez
dit sur vos remarques sur les circuits
courts sur les rh et c'est ce qui me
permet de dire un mot sur les ehpad
qu'en répondant aussi en partie à la
question du président kenner nous nous
pensons que nous pourrions complètement
gérer les ehpad des ja qui est des
règles que la rs soit là pour surveiller
enquêter venir voir soit très présentes
naturellement dans la partie
réglementaire et surveillance de des
ehpad
mais cette espèce moi je trouve cacher
fois face et comme les c'est comme les
directeurs d'administration centrale qui
dépendent de deux ministres on est sûr
qu'ils fassent ce qu'ils font ce qu'ils
veulent
chaque ministre croit que c'est l'autre
qui les dirigent et vice et versa donc
je pense qu'un système dans lequel nous
aurions la compétence et pas de très
clair avec une surveillance bien sûr
régalienne de la rs serait serait bien
meilleur sachant qu'il ya à l'énorme
chantier sur les ehpad très coûteux
c'est le chantier la rénovation
thermique nous eussions eu le
confinement en chambre individuelle des
pensionnaires des ehpad pendant une
période de canicule
c'est pas quelques dizaines de milliers
de morts mais
ça aurait été beaucoup plus en général
une pièce climatisée qu'est la grande
salle de réunion de repas etc
mais les chambres ne le sont pas donc
quand on enferme des personnes pendant
plusieurs semaines dans une chambre ça
va au mois de février au bas de mars
mais ça va moins bien dans les jours de
grande chaleur et donc est un chantier
énorme de rénovation thermique des
époques comme d'ailleurs les communes
sont bien conscientes
on nous tous d'ailleurs qu'un chantier
aussi de rénovation thermique de tous
les établissements d'enseignement ne
peut pas ouvrir une fenêtre dans son
édition à collège parce que partir d'un
certain étages à sont bloqués pour que
les enfants ne se jette par la fenêtre
moralité on peut pas erré quand il fait
chaud ne peut pas erré candia des
microbes ou des bactéries donc voilà
c'est quand même quelque chose on a on a
un énorme travail à faire en la matière
mathieu darnaud peut pas poser la
question des routes
alors d'où notre idée c'est quand même
le volontariat c'est à dire que les
départements qui sont volontaires pour
reprendre des routes nationales
seulement ceux qui sont volontaires le
fassent ce qu'ils ne veulent pas
l'étaler garde point on à peu près
n'accorde de jean 26e djebbari de
jacqueline gourault sur ce thème alors
ça après il ya des routes compliqué en
prenez l'exemple de la route nationale
10 au nord de bordeaux c'est le plus
gros axes de transport de poids lourds
en france comme l'a dit c'est à péage
tout ce qui remonte d'espagne du
portugal faire toute l'europe se
retrouve sur cette malheureuse
nationales gratuites à quatre voies
comme l'éco taxe est hélas morte
y'a pas de moyens évidemment de l'autre
et physique qui peut gérer ça ça
traverse la gironde ça traverse
charente-maritime la charente les deux
sèvres la vienne jusqu'à poitiers
ensuite une partie par vers l'est à
angoulême vers limoges la région
lyonnaise la fameuse route centre europe
atlantique qui a fait l'objet de plus de
disques aux quatre kilomètres de bitume
donc
qu'est ce qu'on fait ce type dax est ce
que l'état les gardes mais est obligé de
garder des troupes uniquement pour eux
quelques axes où est-ce qu'on fait des
syndicats mixtes l'inter départementaux
pour les gérer a fire est bien question
sur un certain nombre dax y compris des
actes qui sont des périphéries de
grandes de métropole où de grandes
villes qui ont à la fois un trafic
national un trafic interdépartementale
et un trafic d'allers-retours quotidiens
donc qu'est-ce que donc il ya beaucoup
de discussions à voir avec l'état qu'on
n'a pas vraiment eu d'ailleurs c'est
resté assez assez lointain sur le terme
ovni je pense que mathieu darnaud a été
extrêmement poli et diplomatique dans
son langage à propose c'était apeu
pourrait pourrait faire pire
moi je vois dans ma région les liens
d'amitié très anciens avec alain rousset
on y va plus on n'y va plus parce que il
suffit qu'un président de paix s'ils
prennent la parole pour raconter un
problème de ce top dans sa commune on
perd une demi heure on peut pas empêcher
les gens de parler mais il ya c'est un
c'était une super idée bien trop de
monde beaucoup trop de monde le fait
qu'ils aient tous les opci d'une
certaine importance et la région les
départements peut-être quelques
métropoles enfin peu les gens qu'on met
d'ailleurs enfin que manuel valls avait
mis autour de la rédaction des contrats
de plan là a cette fois ci mais la fois
d'avant trouver un niveau 1 niveau de
communauté d'agglo département région on
arrivait à faire des choses mais il ya
beaucoup trop de monde
est-ce qu'il faut un bureau de la ct ap
tout le monde doit être au bureau donc
ça sera encore pire
donc c'est en réalité il faut faire des
choses pas prévu par la loi
il faut que le président de région voit
tous les deux mois les présidents
département il faut que présente
département voit tous les deux mois les
présidents de pci de leur département
faut faire du il faut faire du cousu
main
c'était aps une belle idée une belle
idée qui sert à rien et est là où
l'absentéisme est terrifiant sortie
c'est terrifiant
à part la bretagne en bretagne les élus
sont toujours des hommes et des femmes
sages sauf au moment des élections
régionales agilité économique des
départements et cher mathieu darnaud à
laon se heurte à la loi n'est autre que
je n'ai pas voté je regrette pas d'avoir
voté ne pas avoir voté parce que on l'a
bien vu pendant la crise
l'état fait un boulot considérable bercy
les régions les opci tout le monde à
aider les entreprises mais il y avait
des trous dans la raquette
elle trouve dans la raquette et quentin
certains départements dans l'ouest et
pas seulement ont voulu combler ces
trous dans la raquette labourot a publié
illico presto comme s'il n'y avait pas
plusieurs gens à faire pendant la crise
une circulaire de 40 pages au préfet
demandant aux dix préfets de déférer
toutes ces délibérations qui avait une
petite connotation économique qui
parfois aller je pense à la manche cher
philippe bas de quelques centaines de
milliers d'euros enfin s'était rendu
dans l'été dans le symbole alors qu'est
ce qu'on a fait on a fait les ânes ya
quoi les a retirés et on les a
transformés en délibération sociale on
n'aide pas les peas rihanna richard mais
au delà d'al-arich heures à l'aller
préfet puis puis déféré mais c'est
exactement la même chose on aider la
personne
et puis le chef d'entreprise bon donc on
voit bien qu'on est on est là dre sur 10
de la loi d'autres et que
en réalité on a reculé par rapport à
l'aise aux entreprises moi je vois dans
mon département une boîte qui n'arrivait
pas à faire ses fans mois avec un simple
coup de fil à la région d'information
dans les trois jours on lui donnait la
trésorerie fait ses fans - avec un jour
à nous rembourser à temps sa part à
bordeaux une région qui est grande comme
l'autriche ou le danemark
le temps que ça soit instruit par les
services administratifs de la région
à la boîte à la fermer voilà donc on a
complexifié les choses alors qu'on
pourrait être dans un système de
délégation
la région pourrait donner délégation
département permanente sous le contrôle
de la région et nous d'ailleurs donné
délégation aussi pour certaines de
compétences aux opci un peu fonctionné
dans tous les sens mais on est un
système de la loi note une loi de
l'extrême rigidité et hypocrite on a le
tourisme dans mon département le
touriste est la première activité
économique mais on n'a pas de compétence
économique mandat la compétence de la
première activité économique
on est on est quand même dans un système
absolument incroyable et je j'aurais
aimé que ce texte le n'ont pas changé
les choses s'agit pas de reprendre des
compétences aux régions pour les
départements ou aux le pci et qu'on
puisse avoir des possibilités de se
substituer les uns aux autres dans la
souplesse est sous contrôle de
l'autorité locale qui se situe et il
n'en est malheureusement pas pas ainsi
et jean vient enfin la dernière remarque
du président caennais reçurent la bloc
de cohérence j'aime bien aussi
l'expression les moins technocratique
elle est plus humaine pour le scolaire
c'est clair or les dix ça ça serait
compliqué pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
à cause du fonctionnement de l'état
c'est à dire que ça serait créée elle à
l'échelle nationale une administration
est extraordinairement importante qui va
créer ses services centraux la direction
de la sécurité civile qu'une petite
direction
va devoir créer ch s'est enfin bref on
va on va créer un monstre parisien a
hébergé en ile-de-france pour gérer tout
ça
[Musique]
et puis soyons clairs les préfets sont
bien contents compte qu'une double
autorité parce que moi j'ai un président
département va jamais refusé de refaire
une caserne en mauvais état un
fonctionnaire à paris qui ne sait même
pas où il a caserne non ariana n'aura
rien à faire et j'ai peur qu'une baisse
de qualité du service à la fois sur la
qualité des centres de secours sur la
qualité des achats de matériel et puis
ya beaucoup de choses qui sont dans
l'articulation et que les communes
favori je pense que j'ai tout ça dans
vos départements la nécessité créer des
points d'eau est un problème majeur pour
les petites communes
moi j'ai les communes d'eyedea mollet
commune de 600 habitants qui devrait
70.2 ocs complètement hors budget donc
on se débrouille un peu avec le préfet
et à douter on se débrouille un peu avec
nos nos politiques départementales mais
bon et donc tout ça nécessite quand même
à une action très terrain et je trouve
que cet équilibre actuel entre le préfet
et le département et les communes est
certes compliqué inexplicable à un
allemand ou en anglais ou un
luxembourgeois avec l'habituelle et
système complètement différent et il
repose aussi sur cette réalité du
volontariat est quand même une la
sécurité civile à la française c'est une
belle invention avec des volontaires et
des professionnels et quelques
militaires dans deux dans de très
grandes villes comme un peu c'est un peu
comme sur nationaliser la snsm ça
marcherait plus parce qu'il ya un type à
paris qui dirait quand la canote doit
partir et puis c'est pas c'est pas le
patron de cadeaux qui dirait le temps le
temps fort si je les sortir le le canot
pour aller chercher les gens qui vont se
trouver en difficulté en mer on peut je
pense que
ces quelques inventions franco française
qui se développe même la snsm s'élèvera
outre-mer où on n'existait pas il ya dix
quinze ans sont plutôt des acquis de
souplesse et j'ai peur du grand service
national centralisait des pompiers avec
ces grèves nationales avec ses
revendications salariales nationale et
avec le fonctionnaire qui décide à paris
là où il faut une caserne où là il faut
devait de wc à bls abella un seul voilà
mais sur le plan de la cohérence
politique patrick kanner a raison de
poser la question naturellement
puisqu'on est devant le régalien juste
un mot les aménager pas répondu
émana d'avoir la tendance ça a beaucoup
baissé en arriver pendant la crise plus
de vols frontières beaucoup plus
surveillé plus de trains bon donc
beaucoup laissé ça repart depuis
quelques semaines avec en particulier à
une nouvelle zone qui n'était pas dans
nos radars sont les canaris donc qui ce
qui entraîne le passage ensuite pas la
péninsule ibérique
alors qu'avant c'est plutôt libye italie
ou tunisie italie la chose
donc ça repart un peu forte tendance
aussi on avait beaucoup de gens
d'afrique subsaharienne burkina guinée
les deux guinées cetera là ça commence à
avoir beaucoup plus de gens de pays de
l'est que le risque sur les afghans un
interne naturellement après
désengagement américain
et
et ça nous coûte très cher puisque
menace est le coût de 40 mille euros par
an département et là on est typiquement
dans ce que disait patrick kanner ça
sonnait vraiment une politique
régaliennes la politique de
l'immigration qui nous est déléguée avec
une prise en charge par l'état tout à
fait insuffisantes et beaucoup de bonne
volonté à du monde associatif de nos
travailleurs sociaux de ce camp quand
vous recevez un garçon qui fait 95 kg
qui dit qu'il a 13 ans avec des enfants
de 7 8 ans d'une famille dont les
parents picole et qui ont été confiées à
la the c'est pas évident pour en dehors
de l'obstacle linguistique pour nos
travailleurs sociaux de gérer ces cas là
pourquoi je rend vraiment hommage
c'est une politique qui mériterait
d'être entièrement revu par l'état ça
veut pas dire qu'on veut pas y
participer mais vous ferait qu'on revoie
les règles quelques mans sont très
hypocrite également méchas la marque
souhaite s'exprimer
merci président cher dominique bussereau
bonjour ma question avait un petit peu
dans le sens de celle de de mathieu
darnaud sauf que vous évoquez les aides
directes aux entreprises et la loi notre
a définitivement me classer les cas
passés les capacités pour certaines
collectivités à aider directement les
entreprises ce sont les régions et les
départements n'ont plus de possibilités
vous l'avait bien dit tout à l'heure
dans les cas que vous avez évoquées par
contre dans la loi nôtre on a évoqué la
solidarité territoriale pour les
départements et on n'a jamais tranché
depuis cette loi notre cette zone un
petit peu grise et qui consiste pour les
départements pourquoi pas faire des
économies en aidant les plateforme
d'initiative locale qui est le prêtent
de l'argent à des
gens qui créent des entreprises par
exemple avec des taux zéro mais aussi et
surtout ce qui nous intéresse
particulièrement en milieu rural les
régions lorsqu'elles font des zones
d'activités ne font des zones
d'activités que d'une certaine taille à
minima de 3 hectares et je ne sais
combien de l'eau par contre ce qui
intéresse nos collectivités
nos communautés de communes ce sont des
petites zones d'activité de six huit dix
loups qui permette de sortir le maçon du
village pour qu'ils puissent avec son
établissement être à l'extérieur et
ainsi avoir beaucoup plus de confort
pour son travail et ça ça n'a jamais été
clairement établie et j'aurais souhaité
enfin je pense que peut être vous aussi
qu'à l'occasion de cette loi cela puisse
être clarifiée donc on peut aussi faire
des conneries impose toujours aidé
d'ailleurs le dernier commerce du
village mais dans ce domaine des zones
d'activités qui sont si importantes
pouvant être pour notre milieu rural
j'aurais souhaité savoir ce que vous en
pensiez vous chers à la marque je pense
la même chose que vous il ya quand même
une petite exception
moi j'ai utilisé dans mon département
par la loi note c'est que le pci pts
délégué l'immobilier d'entreprise au
département et donc moi j'ai un grand et
pc d'une centaine de communes qui est un
regroupement de quatre ou cinq petites
communautés de communes cantonales et
qui n'a pas de gros moyens parce que
justement il accueillit la queue des
dépenses de fonctionnement il s'est pas
créé sur un sur un projet de pci
d'investissement ou de un projet de
projet et on a repris l'immobilier
d'entreprise sa demande et ça fonctionne
assez bien et ça je suis en train de
voir que ça donne envie à d'autres pci
nous confiait là nous le confier parce
qu'ensuite on peut agir avec nos scènes
départementales de toute manière pour
aider mais ça pourrait être à l'invs
précisé dans ce texte
naturellement parce que tout le monde a
faim moi j'ai essayé d'utiliser toutes
les failles de la loi no autres pour
essayer de continuer à faire du concret
est aussi quelque chose qui ne
fonctionne pas un joug lycées les
transports les transports le texte de
madame bornes la loi mobilité et elle
dit que les communautés de communes
peuvent se saisir de la mobilité locale
moi j'ai je vois dans la pqr tous les
jours enfin que c'est la période de vote
est terminé
pendant la période de choix tous les
jours c'était les opc qui disaient non
on prend pas la compétence mobilité donc
ça peut transférer la région sauf que
les régions elles ont suffisamment à
faire éclore difficultés avec le ter et
leurs réseaux ferroviaires pour aller
sans qu'ils aient à faire de la mobilité
locale
elles ont pas les techniciens les
équipes donc elles font pas donc on va
avoir
on va avoir dichotomie sur le territoire
entre des endroits dans la ruralité où
il y aura de la mobilité
parce qu'un le pci qui avait un peu plus
de moyens ou qui était oui akhavan élu
passionné par sa s'y est mis et puis
quelques-uns ou des régions parce que
c'est symbolique vont le faire
une grande majorité de pc où il y aura
pas de mobilité organisée rurale parce
qu'il ya un trou dans la raquette et là
encore on avait dit allez isabelle borne
laisser la possibilité au département si
la région refuse
et si le département l'acceptent et si
le pci demande
laissez-nous la possibilité de ont comme
on transporte les enfants handicapés
toujours des équipes spécialisées de
devenir les aider et cette là encore et
c'est ça que qui m'énerve c'est que l'on
propose pas le grand soir
on propose des possibilités de
délégations entre les uns et les autres
est ce qui est quand même assez simple
et dans un pays où les élus ont
l'habitude de travailler entre eux
puisqu'on sait tout sur le terrain
comment ça se passe on parle de là les
étiquettes politiques tout le monde
travaille avec tout le monde mais dans
certains cas c'est la loi et c'est
dommage qu'ils apportent les rigidités
et 7,4 des ça peut être pour vous
l'occasion et nous permettront de
soumettre rapporteur un certain nombre
d'amendements au projet d'amendement de
mettre de la souplesse de l'huile dans
les rouages de la de la décentralisation
monsieur philippe bas et monsieur
richard merci monsieur le président et
j'écoute avec beaucoup d'attention et
d'intérêt les réponses de dominique
bussereau que je remercie c'est vrai que
les uns et les autres nous avons au
cours des dernières années
refuser de nous inscrire dans la
perspective d'un grand soir pour
reprendre l'expression du président
bussereau bons on approche tout de même
d'une élection présidentielle
et si on se borne à ne réfléchir cas des
ajustements on n'est peut-être pas à la
hauteur des défis
je crois que si nous n'avons pas voulu
de grands soirs jusqu'à présent c'est
que nos élus locaux et je parle en
premier des mères en ont par-dessus la
tête des changements accélérés qu'ils
ont subis ces dernières années mais il
est vrai que l'articulation entre
départements et régions posent des
problèmes
on a dû remballer le projet du
conseiller territorial
il est devenu impossible à réaliser avec
les grandes régions tout le monde
s'accorde à dire que les grandes régions
n'ont pas suscité d'affection societatis
pour prendre l'exemple de la normandie
venant de la manche pour aller au centre
de rouen pour rencontrer le président de
région
un président de conseil départemental
doit mobiliser 5 heures de trajet dans
sa journée et en vérité malgré tous les
efforts d'ailleurs réussi de notre
équipe
régional pour créer de la proximité
le centralisme régional ne vaut guère
mieux que le centralisme d'état et je
crois que à différer l'examen de ces
questions
trop longtemps on court le risque
d'installer dans le paysage une
structuration régional qui s'est révélé
en réalité très difficile acclimaté
alors je pose une question là qu'il y
est très difficile de répondre quand on
est président de l'association des
départements de france et qu'on vit dans
l'unité avec l'association des maires de
france comme avec l'association des
régions de france
mais enfin j'ai quand même envie non pas
pour refaire le monde mais peut-être
pour refaire un peu la carte
territoriale de la france de demander si
vraiment c'est un tabou indépassable que
de considérer que la réforme très
technocratique de recomposition des
régions avec l'idée au fond qu'il faut
pour qu'une région soit efficace il faut
pas qu'elle existe vraiment dans la
géographie humaine
il faut qu'elle ait un nombre donné
d'habitants alors si les allemands
raisonner comme ça il faudrait vraiment
qu'ils suppriment bardach la sarre et
qui coupe en trois la bavière
l'idée de région à taille européenne est
une vue de l'esprit
ce qui est important pour un territoire
c'est que la population est un sentiment
d'appartenance à ce territoire où elle
sentiment d'appartenance au territoire
d'une grande région et comment peut-on
faire la loi de 1972 du 5-juillet 72
n'était pas si mauvaise pour envisager
au fond un avenir dans lequel la région
deviendrait une inter départementale it
et agissant pour le compte des
départements pour mettre en oeuvre des
compétences que les départements ne
peuvent plus assurer tout seul voilà la
question
je m'accommode ray d'une d'une réponse
est lui dans une partie du problème
monsieur le président parce que je ne
veux pas vous mettre dans l'embarras
mais la question est posée
mais chez richard nous payer d'impôts
essayez de résumer les heures de
discours que nous avons commencé à
écouter et que nous allons continuer à
entendre à propos de la répartition des
compétences entre collectivités je
rappelle l'existence de l'article 1108
du code des collectivités territoriales
qui permet sans aucune limite aux
collectivités détenant une compétence
d'en déléguer l'exercice à n'importe
quel autre monsieur bussereau gens je
commence à répondre à richard que les
biens ces questions faudrait-il encore
que les préfets le connaissent main et
enée pas des circulaires de leurs
ministres de leur mini c'est la dgcl
leur disant de déférer je vais vous
donner un exemple extraordinaire en
bretagne un grand préfet smir manque est
un grand préfet de la république le
département d'ille-et-vilaine financer
ses casernes de pompiers ce que je fais
aussi pour enlever aux 12-17 charge et
que les charges issues du sdiss soit
naturellement sur les pompiers matériel
les offres de recrutement etc
déferré j'ai dû aller vers la mise de
l'intérieur pourtant c'est un des mes
nos meilleurs préfet savoir le mise à
l'intérieur pour lui expliquer que ça
fasse est absurde et mais intérieure se
castaner à l'époque on a naturellement
convenu et le nombre de préfets qui ont
différé qui ont déféré devant la juge
administrative des délibérations des
départements pendant la crise sanitaire
du printemps dernier est incroyable
donc
réalité la dgcl et la dgcl joue au lieu
d'être ce qu'elles étaient
historiquement dans notre pays
connaissez bien
c'est à dire une direction d'ed aux
collectivités et venir il dirait une
direction qui pond des circulaires pour
empêcher les collectivités de faire ce
qu'elles ont envie de faire donc il faut
en modifier la nature et l'objet se met
pas en cause les hommes le directeur
général et ses équipes font ce que le
pouvoir politique leur demande mais
c'est quand même pas c'est quand même
pas très de ce qu'on attend d'eux en la
matière voilà ça c'est une première
remarque quant aux régions
philippe balle a dit avec beaucoup
d'humour tout c'est très complexe
je vois ma région dans la même nuit et
françois hollande qui me l'a raconté
plus tard nous sommes passés de d'être
exploités ou charente avec les pays de
la loire puisse concevoir façade
littorale
nantes capitale au lieu de bordeaux ou
même si on est naturellement tourné vers
bordeaux aura bon l'avant des proches et
c'est un moment c'est le truc la région
centre c'est à dire qu'on allait l'île
de ré au péage de saint-andré d'arnoult
bon et puis dans la nuit
les choses ont évolué à nouveau et on
s'est retrouvé ce que nous avions
souhaité avec l'aquitaine mais on nous a
rajouté limousin qui voulaient pâle avec
l'auvergne avec la région centre après
on arrive donc à une région que auquel
alain rousset laquelle alain rousset
c'est de donner un sens et nous tous
parce que c'est une vraie métropole
qu'est bordeaux en fac que les toits y
avait des liens entre limoges et
poitiers lignac du monstre limoges
bordeaux et entre guéret et bordeaux
étaient assez ténue corrèze encore il ya
le
ya le rugby et la creuse et bordeaux
c'était assez ténue bon c'est d'y
arriver mais où ça se complique c'est
l'état c'est que croyons bien faire le
gouvernement de l'époque a mis la dréal
pour ça reste pas loin de ségolène à
poitiers la draf à limoges ce qui fait
que le préfet de région n'a pas ces
directions sous la main que font ces
directions régionales être avec leurs
centrales
et dès que ses politiques avec le
cabinet et quant aux préfets de
département ils voient des mails 15
jours après donc lors on a on a croyant
bien faire organiser un fonctionnement
de l'état pour essayer de maintenir des
sites avec des fonctionnaires ce qui se
comprend très bien en termes d'emplois
de qualité de vie des familles etc mais
qui rend l'action de l'état pas aussi
bonne qu'elle pourrait l'être quelles
que soient les qualités notre préfet de
région
voilà donc je pense que si on revoyait
ses cartes manière ou d'une autre pour
voir les cartes des compétences ou des
cohérences pour reprendre l'expression
du président kader mais il faudrait
aussi revoir l'organisation de l'état et
on voit bien que les préfets dans nos
départements
aujourd'hui sont sous staff et ils sont
ils sont saouls staff et quand ils ont
une question il songer à une direction
régionale qui elle même ne s'en réfère à
l'administration centrale
et voilà donc il faudrait parallèlement
est une réforme de l'organisation de
l'état territorial organisation de
l'état parce qu'actuellement on a voulu
on a voulu tenir qu'on a ça tombe
équilibre et sa re et ça entraîne en
effet je ne vois bien dans la campagne
régionale dans toutes les régions de
france il ya toujours quelqu'un qui
critiquent le président sortant quelle
que soit son étiquette politique sur le
fait qu'il a créé un centralisme
régionales et c'est vrai que le mode de
scrutin le très grand nombre d'élus la
grandeur des régions font que
l'administration régionale aprilia a
pris un poids très important et parfois
au détriment des élus dans la plupart de
nos régions et les présidents sont sur
les routes avec leurs piles de
parapheurs et pas à diriger leurs
équipes au quotidien et leur vice
présidents sont un peu dans le même cas
merci une dernière question qui est
celle de monsieur kerrouche à la merci
aussi on tient le dr donc monsieur
gayraud chute je vais aller vite parce
que c'est surtout une réaction à la
prise de à la prise de parole de deux
slims bas
j'entends l'importance du du département
qui est une réalité historique depuis ou
en 1790 à lalita historique quand même
qui est également je le rappelle a
contesté depuis la fin du 19e siècle
puisque mes maîtres départementaux ont
toujours été où ils sont encore parfois
difficile en termes de les volumes
investis sur rien mis en relation avec
l'évolution de avec l'évolution de la
population
donc c'est une institution qui est tout
à fait légitime et ont créé dans dans
les territoires mais dont on peut aussi
questionner les périmètres au même titre
que en questionner périmètre à giono sur
l'histoire du du conseiller territorial
on avait déjà une volonté en fait de
départementalisation de la région qui ne
s'est pas fait avec les grandes régions
et quand même les grandes régions sont
faites
a priori quand on regarde le niveaux de
gouvernement ailleurs en europe ou
repenser l'aménagement du territoire l2
économique manière structurante et il
s'agit pas d'un ter département dans la
plupart des pays qui nous entourent
il s'agit bien de logique d'aménagement
du territoire avec une institution
intermédiaires qui pilote ces
territoires
s'agissant des grandes régions et je
pense que le président bussereau l'a
bien synthétisé il ya eu l'évolution ddd
grande région dont on peut dire
d'ailleurs qu'elles ne sont pas
forcément pertinente partout mais le
problème ne remonte pas une grande
région il remonte au choix que nous
avons fait de manière collective à
chaque niveau institutionnel c'est à
dire le fait qu'un de pc fusionne avec
un autre pays et qu'il est difficile
pour une commune de sortir d'un homme
pci et le fait que en fait il est
difficile de sortir un département d'une
région et que comme nous avons réfléchi
dans des périmètres régionaux alors
qu'ils aient pas de dislocation des
futurs des futures régions on avait des
difficultés mais cette difficulté
d'homologie on a on l'a toujours eue sur
chacune des deux institutions
mais le vrai problème c'est que
effectivement l'état n'a pas suivi en
matière de en matière de déconcentration
et que on a eu une évolution
institutionnelle en ce qui concerne la
région
pas partout je le rappelle est que pour
autant dans le même temps l'état
territorial n'a pas suivi de la même
façon donc effectivement là on a deux
tracés qui ne sont plus qu'ils ne sont
plus parallèle et qui nous pose des
difficultés au quotidien et la vrai
problème aussi c'est que d'une certaine
façon la loi ton des discussions
initialement cette loi ne résout pas ce
problème de déconcentration est quand
même un problème majeur parce qu'on peut
difficilement continuer avec une
disjonction de l'état territorial d'une
certaine façon elle ces collectivités
territoriales merci madame merci et
c'est vous qui concluaient les questions
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président
chez vous et écoutez avec gourmandise
parce que vous parlez de faire du
concret et c'est exactement ça que ce
qu'est ce que demandent nos habitants
c'est du concret et ils demandent en
fait des circuits courts
un circuit court de la décision un
circuit cours de l'action c'est ce qui a
été fait en saône et loire vous avez eu
la gentillesse de parler d'eux du
problème de santé du président hakkari
qui était au bord de la légalité puisque
c'est pas une compétence du département
mais qu'est-ce qu'on a recherché juste
le bien-être de nos habitants qui
avaient besoin de médecins qui avaient
besoin de médecin traitant
donc quel est le besoin qu'est ce qu'on
met en face et qu'est-ce qui manque
toujours c'est pas de réfléchir c'est
pas de faire tout un tas de notes ce qui
manque toujours c'est cette période
d'observation et la période
d'observation elle est dans les
départements avec des élus de terrain
qui colle aux demandes de leurs
habitants merci merci cela appelle des
commentaires je vote les amendements
kerrouche et mercier
[Musique]